Before I move on to the next slide, does anyone have any questions so far?
Yes, I do.
You said the company faces many challenges now.
Beyond the economic situation, what is your biggest single challenge?
Well, that's a good question and I was planning to talk about it.
As I showed you, our revenues grew for 10 consecutive years.
But now, the market is highly saturated.
Unless we open new geographic markets,...
...or develop a new product for the existing markets, our growth period is over.
Actually, that is why I am here with you, to explore new market opportunities.
Our company was a pioneer in this market 10 years ago,...
...but since then, many competitors have entered this market.
It is critical not only to develop leading-edge products that differentiate us,...
...but to look for partnerships, which we will discuss later.
The other big issue is finding the right people... particularly young, innovative engineers.
It is getting harder to attract enough good engineers.
We still have open positions in our Engineering Department...
... that we haven't been able to fill for three months, even in this job market.
I can relate to that issue. We have a similar problem here, too...
...although it's a "moot point" because we can't afford to hire new people at the moment anyway.